I
the thing about theater is that it
actually only can happen with an
audience and that is a defining feature
of this art form you can write a poem
you can paint a painting put it on a
wall you can write a book it can exist
in the world but theatre really cannot
exist except with an audience and one
might say well you've got your play
script in your hand you've got your
penguin pocket classic edition of a
Shakespeare play that's theater as
literature but life here not only can
only happen with an audience but in many
ways it happens inside the audience's
head so so for me as a director I've
always felt the audience is the partner
you know and we think in our profession
you know you think about the writers you
work with the actors all the people that
make the art form and yet for me the
audience completes it and that has not
always been I think a point of view that
has been shared I think because so many
people feel that an audience can pollute
your artistic intention or bring it down
or you can't pander to an audience and I
think especially in in 20th century art
there was a move towards a kind of
cultural elitism where there was a sense
that well an audience doesn't really
know what they want so you've got to
give them something that they may not
know what they want I think for me my
roots are in a kind of populism so I
have total faith and confidence in an
audience and I believe an audience wants
to be yes entertained but they also want
to think they want to be stretched they
want to feel alive they want to feel
their heart pound that's why we go to
the theater so I've always found the
audience
as a driver of the process and I've sat
on many panels with other artists who
say well you know yet why do you think
by the audience you know no I got to
think about my art for me art comes from
the end result of thinking what what is
the audience want why are they going to
bother to come out of their busy lives
to be in a theater you know for two to
three hours to me that's a super
generous act so I I want to think about
the audience as a collaborator the great
thing about theatre is that it is life
and even though you've made a thousand
decisions when you direct a production
and the play has been written or the
music's been scored there is this
presence of performance that can change
day to day and it's what makes our art
form so special at what's drives it's
also what drives us crazy you know being
a theater person I remember being in a
seminar with a number of filmmakers and
all the theater people looked at the
film makers and said oh my god you've
got it so easy you get that performance
on on tape and you've got it forever and
you know in the theater you've gotta
rehearse it you've got to recreate it
maybe it happens once in a rehearsal how
do you get that actor to that level the
next time when you hit the scene again
let alone eight times a week in a show
that's running on Broadway and the funny
thing is and I'll never forget this the
filmmakers in that group said but you
can change you can change what you're
doing you can respond and it was a an
anecdote that was told about Jacques
Tati a very famous filmmaker and I've
never forgotten this this this story
that he would screen a film and then in
between the showings he would go to the
control booth and with the scissors try
to edit the film because he had learned
something for the audience and he was
like Natalie trying to just cut and
paste his film too
to change it based on what he had
learned and I always say to the artists
i'm working with particular actors we
get to respond the earth is rotated it's
a new day events in our our lives will
impact what an audience is feeling when
they come to the ER tonight the air were
breathing is actually different and if
you can actually embrace that then you
will achieve that kind of presence which
you can only get in the theater now
having said that I think we all know
we've been to the theater and you don't
feel alive I mean I I done theater all
my life and I'd go to see a lot of
theater and I've even felt that myself
you know you can actually go to a
theater event and feel like it's
hermetically sealed like you could be
there or not and you're not impacting it
you could as an audience member perhaps
fall asleep in a show which you know
I've done which you know you go to any
number of shows you've seen you kind of
look up and down the myth the theater
and you know maybe someone sleeping and
it doesn't have an impact so I think
this question of how does an audience
actually impact a show is at the heart
of what makes theatre theatre and I
think for me I in the 21st century where
I sit making shows I want to push that
presence of an audience what do I mean
by that I want an audience to feel
entitled and empowered to respond you
know I do a lot of Broadway musicals and
when I'm in my shows in the audience and
I hear people around me singing the
lyrics I love it I love it that an
audience is so connected that they want
to sing along now of course for some
other audience members it drives me
crazy you know they turn around they're
likely you please ask that person be
quiet I i like to push theater because
that's what we do in our art form to a
place where an audience can express
themselves you know like you would a
great sporting event I I often say
the problem with the theater is you know
you say what profession are you in and
you say well I do the theater and I also
think you know would you ever say like
Oh what profession are you and I do
sports you never say that and their
codes and etiquette for all different
kind of sporting events and you can
appreciate that at a golf match or I was
just at the US Open you know you have to
be quiet or you'll be asked to leave
right the serve goes you've gotta like
you can't influence you have to kind of
be invisible and that's serving the
concentration of the game you go to a
basketball game you know you're on the
behind the net and it's a foul shot
you're supposed to pick up your foam
finger and like do everything you can to
distract the player that's your job as
an audience so those are two different
you know audience behaviors all on this
continuum of sports and I think we tend
to feel that in the theater your job
because most of us have this experience
when you go to the theater as an
audience you arrive you get your program
you might arrive with friends but you
then sitting in a line and seats bolted
to the floor the lights go out you're
supposed to be quiet if you talk back to
the stage you probably would be asked to
leave because that's not good audience
behavior and then you know the show
happens you either are very entertaining
you cry you laugh maybe you fall asleep
the show ends you applaud usher says
please leave and to me that's not the
history of theatre that's one one
example of a behavior of theatre and
that that behavior was very much defined
by a radical turn you know at the
beginning of the 20th century with
naturalism you know when we were coming
out of a time of you know public
spectacle as theater and vaudeville
houses in America where you talked back
and you know there was this radical
movement of like no you know the
audience should be invisible you should
be of wire you know looking through a
peephole and you know that's right in
line with Richard Wagner saying you know
I can't stand the polluting of the art
form turn the lights out put the
audience in the dark you know the
audience's weren't in the
mark always you know the audience was
lit in the theater because that was part
of the social experience you went to the
theater not only to see a show but you
went to the theater to be seen in be
seen and you know a 19th century opera
house with its gold gilt ornate
balconies and chandeliers was like the
modern-day nightclub you know you were
watching an incredibly evocative opera
but you were also looking at who was in
the box and sort of flirting with them
because that's what you did and it was a
social space and it was radical to say
you know put all that aside that's
that's all distraction let's be
invisible let's just silently watch and
and you know the although art that came
out of that you know this Stanislavski
and check out that was radical in its
time but I think we've inherited that
and we think that's all theater is or
can be and I I now believe that if we're
going to make the theater vital and
necessary we have to return it to its
roots where the audience's voice matters